river river how you learn has nothing to
do with how brilliant you are fine
it's fine
this touchy moment on the Kelly Clarkson
show has us reaching for the tissues
there's a lot of Hearts involved here
about the most important ones Kelly's
two kids seven-year-old son Remington
and eight-year-old daughter River who
has dyslexia a learning disability many
A-list stars have experience with one
and they appointed children I know so
it's it's more common that I didn't I
didn't know that but
I know and they're pointing out um you
know Captain America Anthony Mackey is
dyslexic like Shazam like Zachary Levi
who else none other than the Fonz
himself Henry Winkler who's authored
Children books inspired by how dyslexia
affected his childhood and career it was
really hard
because I never knew why I was failing I
tried so hard to be successful in these
halls and I my brain was wired
differently reading around the table
when I got Happy Days every Monday at 10
o'clock I was embarrassed for 10 years
now I find that amazing to tell my
daughter that you've written like 40
books and you're dyslexic because she
was getting bullied like at school for
not being able to read the greatest kids
she's second but I have books first but
they said I know I have I've been
reading oh yes yes yes so wait but I
that's when Henry goes full Mr Rogers
looking straight to camera with an
empowering message for Kelly's
eight-year-old how you learn has nothing
to do with how brilliant you are
[Applause]
fine
it's fun
it was an ongoing process it holds on
like it digs into your psyche with claws
and you have to take each claw and rip
it out of your mind and cut it off your
bone that
you're not only are you enjoying your
dream
but you're not who they said you were
and we're fine
of course Kelly's not afraid to unleash
the Waterworks kala surprised me most
she can make you cry
um after the first three notes that's
rare just this week she got emotional
during a contestant performance on The
Voice
[Music]
right then that's what you want from a
performer wow
[Applause]
between emotional performances and
heartfelt messages in her day jobs
Kelly's Glam Squad has their work cut
out for them and we're fine
it's fine my makeup artist is gonna kill
me it's so nice
[Music]